hello and welcome to this video the FISC
again now I've got black okay so that's
Roble when they think it means I take on
f7 at least sometimes that is the case
okay the the crumbling line now that's
what chrome league played against
Khurana in the candidates led to a
little very fascinating game actually so
of course that is not a very critical
continuation it doesn't challenge black
in some in some direct way but yeah we
just have to play this game now without
Queens what black is trying to do is
some long term do something maybe with
the whites double pawn but 94 is very
often just too good
good recipe so how to play him
just going to complete development here
there should be six next I don't want to
be arrested by 95 what has a little bit
more space but John this is not a ray
all that relevant I think the position
is just equal one absolutely key element
of such such plane if you are in a blitz
game and you want to win and I do want
to win even though it doesn't look like
it with this opening and everything and
one key element is to never ever ever
ever ever get it a time flower you want
an ending here which is roughly equal I
mean if he makes a mistake and I'm
better I'm happy of course but just a
normal kind of position where you have
more time and then there will be quite
often moments where there is some
problem to solve
and then that is the mode where you have
to hope that having more time is useful
what is going on yeah is attacking my
points I can't go d5 simply yeah let's
do it
yes sir rather equal ish the rook looks
odd though if I call Bishop c5 and
attack this pawn and one day I'll trap
the Rope here it's not not really
Bishop g3 now I guess hmm and the Rukh
is still I cannot trap it okay I'm going
to make the light squared Bishop Mobile
I'm fading the idea to play Bishop d7
but who what's going on like it I take
it right it's that trick I don't see the
trick why can I not take it this has
some meat or I'm tactic or what is going
on you should tanks no to the truck I
just take it I just take it
there was a blot maybe he has some some
grand idea I don't really see anything
it looks like he wants to try to get to
walk back into the game suddenly good
idea still how do we do that I can go be
sex look takes King be seven rook a 4d v
rook a five king b6 and it's trapped
okay
physics takes King B seven okay form b5
look f5 King b6 it's trapped it is just
trapped look a for a go King b7 first
cover everything and then b5 next I
cannot play rook a 4 B 5 lu k 6 SC 6 the
same two times I just don't see it
I think I'm trapping this rook
yep trapping it just go on but it's
probably a reasonable defensive tribe
the only thing is I can immediately
trade bishops and that helps okay so
what's the winning idea probably
probably some c3 at the right moment
okay good that's not a bad idea
mm-hmm okay I'm asking him away goes
King detour fc3 and then I can invade
with a king he avoided that hmm that's
that's a good decision okay yeah this is
still still a bit of work him
how do we win on the kingside probably I
have to go f6 g5 and get - oh that is
probably helpful king t1 I have to
invade King e6 and I have to combine
invading ideas with the king and rook
that should be possible him rook t1 and
if he moves the King I'm entering yeah
look T - well it looks good need to do
that
it's useful to have all the points on
light squares so I can have a blunder
anything it was a bit of odd to the
position was of course quite equal and
then all of a sudden he played C form
I'm not surprised that the engine gives
me a slight edge already the the reason
is that this look is really a bit odd
it's it's difficult to get it into
safety without any any issues and
another thing is that I mean this little
fact that I'm attacking this pawn and
here defends it with the bishop it gives
me some ideas like f5g five pushes while
his pawns are not able to push because I
mean bishops are founder the pawns
so I already have a little bit of more I
have a little bit more ideas him it's so
nothing substantial I have to smooth
warm however I'm just winning I think
this just doesn't work and b6 is not
necessary but I think it wins pretty
straightforwardly like here King here
here king b6
please not this one it would be
embarrassing but King b6 winds to walk
just what is okay I actually if I take
it there is Bishop c7 but I'm still
winning I have this one it's not a rook
it's a beast
yeah so we decided to sacrifice on c5
but now it's a relatively simple task
I mean I took a bit of time and I could
have been a bit quicker but it was not
really I think a question that black
wins yeah okay guys thanks for watching